Tendai mercy was sixteen-year-old son
broke his leg last month she took him to
a public hospital only to be told
doctors have been on strike over pay and
wages for more than a month her son's
been admitted but she says all nurses
can do for him is keep him comfortable I
don't have x-ray vision I can't see
what's happening inside his leg what if
it is infected and rotting we are
begging the government to talk to the
doctors Patrick Azaria and his
seven-year-old son Blizzard were told to
come back after a month when maybe the
strike will be over is just a charm
or they had to do is remove his cast
they say only specialists can do that I
don't understand they are meant to care
for the sick it seem heartless until
there is a breakthrough
Zimbabwe's public hospitals are barely
functioning doctors have long complained
about pay and working conditions they
want their salaries in u.s. dollars or
the equivalent amount at the official
bank rate last week unions rejected the
government's offer of a 60 percent
salary increase saying after deductions
they are taking home basically nothing
this is the entrance to the casualty
ward usually it's busy with many people
coming in and out but several patients
say they've been turned away only
emergency cases are being treated where
possible contingency measures have been
put in place some of the awards have
been combined for his of provisional
services and government has requested
assistance from uniformed the forces we
have doctors from the army from the
police as well as from prisons the
country is suffering its worst economic
crisis in a decade president Emma Simon
and Gaga says bringing the economy back
from the dead needs patients but those
words would be difficult to accept for
frustrated doctors and those who need
medical care fuel prices go up every
week that means everything else
drastically increases for the poor
living in Zimbabwe is becoming in
recently challenging her Matassa
al-jazeera Harari